[Music]
[Music]
three to my favorite meme depicts a
lemon with a caption underneath it that
says like when life gives you lemons and
underneath that picture it depicts a
Buddha's hand with a caption underneath
that picture that says Fung gluey me
glue ah wanna lay a Cthulhu feet again
which of course is absolutely hilarious
if you know what a Buddha's hand is
google it look it up with me is dr. Greg
Lee Gregory B Sandler how are you doing
today Gregory B Sadler I'm doing good
I'm glad to be back
I'm glad that you're back - I am glad
that you're also front you are for most
of philosophy in Milwaukee how does that
make you feel I think it is the case I
think you are Milwaukee's philosopher
well that's cool you might even be our
philosopher king well nobody's given me
any power yet so oh just wait till the
election yeah yeah we gotta wait for
another one to come up for that oh we
gotta wait aren't you the kid we just
had one ah dang it we can't like run
rush won in don't they do that in
Britain and Britannia they're like oh
yeah looks good let's have another
election Australia they if they have
some sort of crisis yeah they can use
crisis snap thing okay thank you okay
this is our lovely assistant Oh slate
I'm sorry I have to we're recording this
on video as well and I've learned to
slate against my face because I don't
have a clap board what do you mean slate
that's when it used to be made of slate
had a chalkboard you write this tape
number and flick it and then you can
line up the audio with the video so you
are making use out of the human body
I am technology that is because I am a
performance artist that is great yeah
that's right hey let's just this
ah yeah a nice speaking into the mic
sideways I just noticed as you turned
towards it was less effective than when
you were turned towards it
uh-oh case in point yeah I can hear it
much better now all right excellent
enough shop Talk tell me about your
other shop you're teaching at my ad
Milwaukee School of Art and Design and
your teaching philosophy we were just
talking about this before the show
started art schools are known for being
not academically rigorous my ad is
breaking the mold on that are they yeah
I you know I've got to say I'll tell you
more about that in just a minute but I
have yet to see an institution that is
more student-centered and better at
assessing whether learning is taking
place than my end and I've worked in a
lot of places how do they wait how do
they yes first of all I've always
thought grades were phony they didn't
give any information about learning so
how do they assess so they use
portfolios and they have you you know
how the students have to upload their
their materials and the students have my
it's like other professional schools
they're they're working on their
specialty but they're also taking you
know a wide array of classes in the
liberal arts or you know in business
sort of like you know the Culinary
Institute of America they do the
culinary baking and pastry right but
they also do liberal arts and business
management because you know you've
course that sort of stuff to communicate
well so my end yeah they're really doing
things well I'm very impressed with with
how they're having a mean they they make
us actually put together rigorous
syllabi seriously yeah and say how we're
going to make sure the students are
actually learning something and that we
can provide evidence I get what's that
evidence we've got assess yeah I had
somebody come into my class and you know
had a rubric taking notes and and gave
me a report afterwards also went to the
chair and I did you know I did well
which is great but it's important to
have these sorts of things in play and I
you know I've taught at some other
places where they they don't always do
things quite so
quite so structured no as dramatically
nobody ever came into any class I ever
took at university yeah now this local
institution when I mean when I was in I
I don't think there was any oversight
whatsoever yeah exactly it's do what you
want yeah I hippies take over yeah I did
great under benign neglect but I think
but I actually loved working with these
professional students you know because a
professional students isn't that like a
non-traditional student a lifelong
student well it means two different
things so you're right there's the
professional learners or the people who
have been in the workforce for a while
okay and then there's you know people
who are specializing in something that's
that's usually seen as a non-traditional
academic subject like you know I
mentioned the Culinary Institute of
America when I work with students there
I really enjoyed it
the my ed students Art and Design you
know they're you what's really cool
about that is if you're gonna teach
something that's not in there they're
wheelwell you really have to make the
case for why it's important to study it
and yeah they're due to be like really
on right your game to teach it well
interesting how do you do that
you know what I learned about
mathematics while I was in college and
well first of all I didn't learn any
mathematics in traditional algebra class
okay I got a d-minus I have a notebook
full of equations all of them are
performed incorrectly they're all wrong
but I took a class called quantitative
reasoning which was all word problems
and then I was like oh yeah okay this is
what I'm trying to figure out this is
the procedure and everything made sense
then well you know that's that's an
important aspect right so when I when I
set up a class and we are talking a lot
of shop before getting into the
lovecraft but when I go to class you
know I know that my students are going
to be different temperaments right there
some of them are gonna do better reading
texts some are gonna do better listening
to podcasts I'm gonna do better watching
videos some are gonna do better getting
charts and you know yeah there's all
those different types of learning yeah
so and then the notion of very rigid
learning styles that's fortunately gone
out the window cuz that was nonsense
I'm a visual learner know you're
somewhere on a spectrum why if you
supply the students with resources to
help so let's say we're teaching Plato's
symposium right which is which is about
you know art okay I'll give the student
lecture videos podcast episodes that
I'll produce from the lecture videos
lesson pages maybe a few links to some
some things that could be useful and
then handouts and the handouts are
downloadable they're you know sort of
putting things into chart form for I
mean I'm I like that sort of thing yeah
yeah it's the everything connects up
yeah and so and then you also have to
does you you have to think about what
you're gonna talk about in class and you
got to make it relevant to them so you
know that's the cool thing about
philosophy
almost all the philosophy up until say
the early 20th century is if you do a
little bit of work it's almost always
directly relevant to students lives and
it sounds like a tough sell sometimes
you know Hegel's phenomenology of spirit
or you know Kant's critique of Pure
Reason but you can do it if you actually
know the text and you're used to
teaching students who don't
automatically give you a pass for being
you know the big professor who does that
come on well fiction if you're teaching
majors right if you're teaching
philosophy me oh okay sure they already
know the lingo they already know that
they're supposed to give you a kind of
deference mhm but if you're teaching non
majors especially if you're teaching
them you know and up in a place that's
not you know in a while situation right
there later prove it exactly they're
like well what do you have to teach me
you know who are you that's not quite
you know Welcome Back Kotter you know oh
sure yeah but just about yeah does what
and what philosophers do you teach oh
well this semester we went through quite
a few we started with some Plato and
Aristotle and then I had Cicero so that
we'd get the Stoics and the Epicureans
we did some augustine then we jumped
forward a lot into Descartes Hobbes
Rousseau Mary Wollstonecraft who did we
do after that Marx
we dropped out Simone de Beauvoir
because I needed to restructure the
class and then we and oh it did Rilke oh
really
yeah letters to a young poet and of
course the great work you know yeah and
then we finished up with her with rents
Eichmann in Jerusalem which is kind of a
downer but an important were these all
um all the readings that you had were
they all focused on aesthetics and art
and no imagination no they are focused
on the notion of human nature and then
all the things that spiral out from that
so some of them did have to do with
aesthetics but a lot had to do with the
nature of relationship so yeah you know
that's something that people can relate
to right I can relate to relationships
what's good what's the evil theory tell
the difference you know how do we know
things oh that's one of my favorites and
that comes up in art school a lot how do
I know things it's a popular this coming
semester yes they've got me teaching
ethics for artists and designers uh-huh
that is gonna be fun
yeah so you know part of its like
traditional ethics class you're gonna
learn some utilitarianism and some
deontology and some virtue ethics and we
talked about how it would apply to
things like should you ever stiff a
client or yeah what if you what if
somebody wants you to make artwork
that's that for evil you know for that
and that has happened that has happened
oh yeah yes but then we're gonna delve
into like well what's the purpose of art
sure or what what makes art valuable
yeah and we'll look at some case studies
like the you know the Banksy shredding
it yeah things along those lines it's
perfect yeah and I like your approach 22
students are already signed up for what
yeah why do they love you well three of
them are students I had in the this
current class okay and I guess that my
ed word of mouth is important but I
think it's they're they're attracted to
the topic you know because in you know
in high school and in middle school in
in this nation we don't teach this sort
of stuff no you know I mean unless you
go to like a Catholic school or or some
other religious school or you're really
fortunate and you get to go to some
well-funded public school work it's you
know philosophy gets taught of some sort
of so I'm sure like the Milwaukee school
of philosophy
when it exists it doesn't it exists only
in Potenza Oh exactly yes or in the
world of forms in our imagination yeah
but you know we don't teach this sort of
stuff and students are really hungry for
them that's true so they are and I was
but rather than in curtailing me I
didn't even really know what existed I
remember having a conversation with a
English professor we were reading the
works of token it was able the Inklings
we're reading the Inklings actually and
I got in a discussion with him after
class and he brought up the neoplatonist
and I somehow said the phrase plato was
a I somehow let out that I thought plato
was a neoplatonist oh yeah that's he
corrected me
that's a nice anachronism but I had no
idea what I was talking about I had no
idea any of this existed I didn't know
anything except that Plato wrote the
Republic that's all I knew
well that's a starting point right right
do something yeah and nobody said hey
read some of this until grad school were
there like hey read Deleuze and guitar e
and Foucault Foucault was actually not a
bad writer but yeah I skipped hundreds
of years of the preliminaries you know
my my wife ran into a similar sort of
situation with with her study and in
philosophy she went off to New York you
know sort of a cultural hotbed and and
they they did the same thing like threw
her right into contemporary continental
theories it's nonsense without with no
background right the Canon yeah exactly
what wouldn't why do they do that well
there's there's a I mean there's
something do they expect us to have
known that because of high school I mean
what model how old is that model that's
like from 1900 where they could expect
that I mean maybe some of the foreign
ones do because they you know if you're
if you're going to like the French lycée
you would have two years of philosophy
Wow
or a German Kim nauseam but even you
know like some of my stuff's been using
the Portuguese national curriculum
because tenth and eleventh grade they
they apparently do stuff on Camus but we
don't do that here no we don't so
there's that and then
I think that there's there's this
perception that like you can just start
with Heidegger and then move on from
there you don't have to read all these
previous people you're right emanating
yourself with reading Aristotle or
Augustine
yeah yeah yeah the guys who did who
wrote how you actually think yeah and
and I mean if you read some of those
continental thinkers like if you read
Hannah Arendt
or you read paul ricoeur they if they
were teaching a class they would have
you reading their style of course yeah
yeah I mean even Deleuze right you know
and I like reading to lose on his own I
don't like reading him so much with with
qatari but but his you know like logic
of sense that's a history of philosophy
and eight with some other things like
Lewis Carroll thrown in but he like you
know he talks about what he says the
Stoics were doing right or sure tax it
was he right oh no I think a lot of time
he's here's the thing with Deleuze yeah
and you can say this about a lot of cool
thinkers who do history of philosophy
you're always getting way more of the
thinker you're always getting more to
lose than you are the thinker they're
talking about so like when you read the
losers book on live Nets you're getting
more to lose than live Nets but that's
okay you know same thing you can say
with with Heidegger on Nietzsche oh yeah
yeah or Heidegger on contour anything
like that
yeah I mean you read these guys for for
for that you want them to it's like
seeing a jazz performance you want them
to riff on a theme exactly that you want
them to be incorporating the old
standards standards yes exactly
they're doing a cover version well in a
way in a sense a cover version way to
jazz more improvisation yeah yeah yeah
really oh and and every once in a while
they'll go into a medley with some other
stuff yeah I I'm a fascinating that
Deleuze through in Lewis Carroll I think
that's brilliant well he liked that all
that sort of nonsense stuff you know he
was course it was one of the the key
themes of his work he he also likes that
stuff when it comes up like in Melville
you know he's got an essay on Bartleby
the Scrivener that's that's that's
pretty good
yeah you know I I'll admit to I
I like to lose way better than I like to
lose Ian's you know no don't we all I
have a question for you it's very
difficult to read philosophy except for
certain writers who are actually very
good writers Foucault the Socrates or
Plato who write well later wrote
Socrates well please act Plato and
Xenophon we're both students of Socrates
and there were other students who wrote
dialogues but we don't have them anymore
and whoever translated these mostly did
a pretty good job they're very readable
they're accessible yeah how do you how
do you do it how do you read philosophy
I can't hardly get through a page oh
well what's your advice to students that
you're teaching now who can hardly get
through you know I give them a pep talk
yeah I tell them because a lot of them
approach it and they have kind of an
inferiority complex they're sure they
actually they tell me that they're
anxious about taking the class and I'll
say you know given the proper support
and what we're gonna do in class you're
up to reading Plato you're up to reading
Descartes you're up to reading you know
these thinkers and I don't expect you to
get everything out of it the first time
anything because I didn't you know ya
know as I've been reading these these
texts for sometimes 20 30 years and I
still find stuff that I I hadn't seen
before
yeah so it's okay to only get you know
25% of what's going on and the first
read and maybe 30% the second read and
you know you just keep working at it in
an iterative way and you get more out of
it and then you know most of the like I
said that most of the ancient medieval
early modern and even you know 19th
century philosophy you can apply it to
your life once you understand what the
concepts are once you've cracked the
code so to speak yeah yeah yeah well you
know somebody like Kant Emmanuel cut he
he's got this jargon that he's using and
it seems like him it's impenetrable
until you understand what these terms
actually mean
but once you've cracked the code and
you've actually gotten past the other
obstacle which is the he can't really
mean that canny but yes he does what
like when Kat says
holiday has nothing to do with your
happiness right does he really mean that
yeah it really means that and then you
sort of follow things out that way
once you've cracked that code then you
can start seeing how to connect it up
with with your own life or your your
environment or your relationships or
your past experiences and then and then
it starts to mean more right for sure
yeah yeah so would you call philosophy
books holy books holy well in what sense
of holy in the sense that holy books are
books that you read over and over again
and they're always unfolding to you oh
yeah we're in like you said you can they
aid your life I say yes
that that's a good way to put it and and
a you can't say all philosophy books are
like that because some philosophy books
are they don't have that depth you know
sir a lot of a lot of the secondary
literature stuff that we well but yeah
well I mean it's the same thing with
secondary theological texts exactly yeah
except for when the secondary
theological text is lines of Augustine
right yeah primary test yeah yeah yeah
so that that and you know some of the
same techniques were applied from
biblical hermeneutics to philosophical
hermeneutics there's that entire
movement within continental philosophy
so yeah they're susceptible of multiple
readings and sometimes you gain more by
reading another book by the same author
and or their letters you know yeah
because a lot of these philosophers will
discuss what what they're doing in their
works in letters that we still have and
I mean not so much the ancients well
some ancients sonica we have a ton of
his letters doing hey oh yeah and Cicero
we've got some of his and we've got a
few of Plato's I don't have any of
Aristotle's do you recommend that a
readers of philosophy focus on one work
one philosopher or should they skip
around or should they do the method of
Plato talks about so and so
so then you go and read so and so and so
and so talks about somebody well I mean
any of those are legitimate to do that's
another question I get asked a lot is
okay what order do I have to read this
yeah I mean you could spend your whole
life reading only Plato or only Deleuze
you could but I think that you would be
bored no but you would you would be
depriving yourself given that there's
more available I mean yeah sure yeah
sort of thing that sort of approach made
sense when we didn't have that many
texts yeah awesome like John Dee who was
rumored to have read every book in the
world
back in 1600 yeah I mean I don't think
would have been possible even that no I
don't think so no I mean there's there's
so much literature I mean after the
Renaissance and and these scholars
started combing through these these
monks libraries and these these
monasteries or they've sort of lost
track of what their holdings were oh
right right and recovering all these
these texts that somebody had copied out
at one time or another no I would you
wouldn't be able to you wouldn't be able
to read through all this stuff but I
want to remember well that's that's
another problem that comes up I used to
get really depressed yeah I would go
into our university library when I was a
grad student and I would look at these
these stacks of books and books and
books and I loved being in the library
but I would you know see I'd walked
through one set of shelves and say I'm
never gonna even read this entire whole
shelf right right or and you know what
the hell am i doing
yeah yeah I know that pain this is
another problem you don't know that the
stuff that you're picking is really the
most important or the best stuff no you
know if the kind of you know take it
take a shot so I mean we have a cannon
and the cannon is useful as points of
reference so you should read some Plato
and you should read some Aristotle and
you should read Stanley Stanley who
Stanley oh okay I was thinking Stan Lee
Rosen or Stanley fish what well that was
great thanks for amplifying my joke
ya know that's a good point but start
with the Canon because it's there for a
reason
yeah and then you know if you don't read
everybody it's okay and and you're gonna
have to the other thing I tell people
too is they're like well which book
should I read first and I was like well
whatever book you read first you're
gonna have to reread it later on because
you're not gonna understand three
quarters of what you're reading so you
know it doesn't matter whether you like
you're gonna begin with Plato do you
have to begin with the apology and then
read you know the the credo and the
Phaedo no you could you could start with
the Republic if you wanted to or you
could start with the Meno or you could
start with you know some other dialogue
because whatever it is you're gonna have
to come back to it yeah and you just
sort of start piecing things together I
think it is important to read widely I
will say that and I think that's one of
the problems with a lot of contemporary
academic philosophers so they don't read
very widely because they specialize yeah
because that's what the system
encourages you to do very much so yeah
and you know admittedly some of them are
probably a little lazy too well I
wouldn't say some you know as in terms
of the profession philosophers read a
lot less than say Dorian's do what more
literature people or they doesn't like
gather know-it-alls oh I read that yeah
I know I know
so that's that's kind of an interesting
question you know I remember when I was
in grad school the philosophers would
sometimes you know we'd all go out to
parties together you know yeah and the
lit people did not like philosophers
because what you know well they're like
a dinner party would be like you know
lit person to bring up some some
interpretation of a work and they'd be
and all the lid people would be like
that's really interesting have you have
you considered this and they'd kind of
build on it and the philosophers would
be like I don't think the text says that
at all as matter of fact I think you're
wrong about this and right about this
and on the lid people their jaws would
just drop and it's almost like you know
you know you were a bad guest but but
that's what was encouraged to the
philosophy department of course and
actually I think that would be a
beautiful discussion but
people can't handle disagreements I was
just thinking about this the other day
actually this morning the other hour I
was thinking at a time when I saw a
movie yeah and we were in the car on the
way back discussing the movie it was the
raid - have you seen the raid - no have
you seen the raid so these are these are
actually the raid is a movie where they
storm a building I might have seen it
who's it it's a it's I think it's either
Taiwanese or Hong Kong no no no I have
the raid - the world expands outside the
building but it takes place a minute
after the raid one ends oh right it's
pretty it's fascinating great actually
on the way back we're discussing it and
somebody said something and I'm like
well I disagree I think blah blah blah
and instant silence yeah it was over
they never invited me over again our
friendship was done you know it's funny
cuz you can have the opposite where
somebody is going to claim that deep
down we're really in agreement you know
I don't like do whatever they can just
why not have conflict on the table you
know and you're like no no we we
disagree about yes can't I talk about
these things this is good you think this
is bad
oh well you know it all depends on how
you look at it yeah you're like no you
can only push it so far that's true well
I think we disagree to disagree well we
often disagree about what our
disagreement means right that's right
that's why that's well that's story of
marriage that's why marriages fail
friendships - and friendships yeah and
business partnerships oh and business
partnerships and employment history yeah
right human interactions war neighbors
neighbors you know I I agreed that I
would lend you the chainsaw for this
amount of time and you you know agreed
you'd bring it back and I don't remember
that conversation oh my goodness I I let
somebody a book of poetry oh never let
books write you're never gonna get back
no exactly he's asked for it back he's
like no you never lent it to me he gave
me a copy the author no well people can
you know there's even Vince his own
stories
yeah and I didn't write my name in the
book and there's no proof yeah what you
need is like a big ex libris stamp right
yeah
or the sticker stolen from never see
that one it's my favorite yeah
or you write a little code in on a
certain page you know right I think well
if you look on page 23 you're gonna see
that you know there's a I don't know
this word is underlined sure yeah well I
don't have that kind of memory I you
know it's like having a safe and you
forget the combination exactly that's me
that's the story of my life so I don't
have combination locks for anything
really no just just key locks just key
locks yeah although I have a handful of
combination locks but I forgot the
combinations yeah so the reason I called
you here today oh yeah Gregory Sadler's
so that you could enlighten us about the
most evil of all philosophers HP
Lovecraft well I suppose you could call
him a philosopher in a way in he's like
an armchair philosopher of well he's not
an evil philosopher as such he's a
philosopher of evil exactly and and
what's really cool about his works is
that our sort of traditional concepts of
evil aren't frightening enough for him
you know
okay give me an example of a traditional
concept of evil well so you know you
think about terrible people that would
attack you you know let's say cannibals
invade and they're gonna first they're
gonna they're gonna torture you and then
they're gonna kill you and then worst of
all they're gonna eat you okay so like a
typical man versus nature man versus
yeah man man versus whatever yeah it's a
situation and we can you know we can be
pretty horrible to to each other I'm not
saying that like no it's true actually
you you can use the word horrific yeah I
mean like when dos Dostoevsky doesn't
have the Elder Gods to cope with right
but there's still like really his
characters are really worried
yeah.but Lovecraft gives us a cosmos in
which it's not just a cosmos you know
like you know these naturalist authors
are like you know nature red in tooth
and claw right it doesn't care about you
at all you know go to the Arctic and
you'll get you'll you know the winds
will destroy you Jack London yeah and
even Conrad is is kind of like that -
right yeah but with Lovecraft
it's not just that the universe doesn't
care about is there's no providential
ordering it's that there is a
intelligence behind it but it's
malignant and it's malignant --ml
malignant intelligences yeah often at
war with each other right and we can't
comprehend just how awful they are or
how many you know like chasms of time
you know we're just like a little blip
yeah in the picture of the the universe
and you know I actually brought some
some quotes here you I mean you've heard
this one before from the call of cthulhu
right yeah most merciful thing in the
world I think is the inability of the
human mind to correlate all its contents
we live on a placid
island of ignorance in the midst of
black seas of infinity and it was not
meant that we should voyage far and so
that's that's a great starting point but
then he's writing at a time
when he's pointing out that the science
is which were supposed to yield us an
intelligible sort of clockwork universe
but they really show us as things are
just totally screwed up and and we don't
know what the hell were - I think says
the science is each straining in its own
direction
have hitherto harmed us little but
someday the piercing the piecing
together dissociated knowledge will open
up such terrifying vistas of reality in
a very frightful position therein that
we shall either go mad from the
revelation or flee from the deadly light
into the peace and safety of a new Dark
Age so we would either follow he's in a
way he's very much in line with nature
right I mean Nietzsche yeah is saying oh
you scientists you know you think that
you're wiping out religion and pushing
enlightenment and that but you're really
just a bunch of
yourself you know you you're just as he
said he said that well you didn't say in
those terms I was what's going on in the
genealogy saying but that's so obvious
now especially with the oh no lock down
against I think there's a lot of people
who are still like true believers in in
science you know they will they think
that like science is this vast unified
project and it represents rationality
and lodge oh well I guess you know I
mean it's obvious to me that now it's
become a religion oh yeah for many
people yeah yeah for instance yeah you
see signs in the street I saw a sign I
was in New Orleans on somebody's house
it said this house we believe in science
and enlisted a few other things that
they believe in you know but it was a it
was this political diatribe we believe
in science yeah and so Nietzsche would
say you are deluding yourself about that
you're you're you know sort of pursuing
this dream of a perfectly intelligible
rational universe that will reward our
our efforts and lovecraft you know and
meetcha and and others are saying no
that's that's just nonsense but with
with Nietzsche you don't have like you
know cyclopean Elder Gods no the Elder
Gods are actually that's that's Derleth
who Esther Lee I yeah yeah really and
and he's an interesting yeah you know
he's from Wisconsin I love him yeah yeah
and so he's our native son and he kept
Lovecraft stories alive by founding our
compress and republishing the stuff and
if it wasn't for him we wouldn't have
what he calls the Cthulhu Mythos what
what Lovecraft called yeah augury what
yeah yes auguri yeah yeah after ya saw
goth whom he considered a more important
than Cthulhu well I don't know that he
said he's more important with with these
old ones I mean the one who's
metaphysically the most important is
awesome a--the right that whatever it is
chaos at the middle of the universe
Piper crawling cast yeah yeah well
that's Nara with them oh yeah well
what's your thoughts thought as a [ __ ]
tripping over these these I know
syllables it's some sort of like he
talks about it like a sort of like a
star sort of like a thing pulsating at
the center you know you love craft talks
it is so wonderful and it's it's blind
it's dumb but but somehow it's it's you
could think of it as like the center of
gravity of of everything so I you could
say maybe that's the most important but
yeah Cthulhu is very important Yannick
saw death is is very important in our
lower low tap ordinary little hole tap
I'm not sure how it's actually supposed
to be pronounced yeah well that's the
thing nobody knows how any of its
supposed to be pronounced truly yeah
and the the chant I read at the
beginning it's all consonants
there's no vowels in it you're like wow
do I sort of like that or polish names
yeah
Oh check check is like that too right
yeah
tough to read sometimes yeah or easy to
read tough to read aloud true very true
yeah I mean I mean that's part of the
thing too is let's say you manage to cut
a deal with one of these old ones and
and somehow they're gonna treat you okay
well one of the other old ones could
wipe you out then because it's not like
they have deals with each other yeah the
whole universe is these great forces
that we barely understand contending
with each other right and to do weird
things that you know they're not good
for us yeah that's a fascinating insight
I think that it what brought he come up
with this it was it something it had to
do with scientific discovery of the time
well I think there are a lot of
ingredients going into it that's part of
it the advance of the sciences you know
he's also a reader of Poe
he credits Poe with having essentially
forged a new path with the weird tale
for sure yes actually the other one of
the passages is from his essay so
natural horror and literature he said
before PO the bulk of weird writers had
worked largely in the dark within an
understanding of the psychological basis
of the horror appeal and hampered by
more or less conformity to certain empty
literary conventions such as the happy
ending virtue rewarded and in general a
hollow moral didacticism acceptance of
popular standards and values and
striving of the author to obtrude his
own emotions into the story and take
sides with the partisans of the
majority's artificial ideas and he says
Poe on the other hand perceived the
essential impersonality of the real
artist and he knew that the function of
creative fiction is merely to express
and interpret events and sensations as
they are regardless of how they tend or
what they prove good or evil attractive
or repulsive stimulating and pressing
and so you know he's Poe is is somebody
incredibly important for him I think
well and for the genre in general he did
invent it yeah well sort of I mean I'm
jelly beat him and well yeah and then
you've got you know his sort of
background you know growing up in
Providence it's kind of gone downhill he
he writes all the time about
antiquarians but he was an antiquarian
himself he was living in in a situation
like that Oh or Lovecraft Lovecraft yeah
yeah and then where else does the rest I
mean he takes bits and pieces of ideas
and then sort of blows them up and it's
just that the idea the vast cosmos in
that we're yeah like Douglas Adams says
a microscopic dot on a microscopic dot
yeah Lovecraft understood that for how
terrible atoms that's funny right it was
but Wednesday Fahd beeblebrox
realized that he was supposed to go
insane yeah right that that's the the
machine that drove you insane yeah it
shows you your place in the universe oh
that's true yeah yeah and and so there's
all of that stuff going on and then I
guess you could say that Lovecraft
is doing what speculative fiction
writers do which is to imagine you know
imagine a color out of space right that
you can't identify
so you've and this is something that's
really key to his his work you know he
uses words like unimaginable or on
articulate a ball or right now yeah
and so he's constantly talking about
what cannot be said mm or cannot be
represented but he does a good job in
trying to represent it so we can't
imagine this is something distinctively
human we we have this power of
negativity we can imagine beyond what we
actually have in front of us so we can
imagine a color that's no color you know
and love craft does that over and over
again there's also you know I mean this
is something that we should probably
think about there's also like a heavy
strain of racism running through
Lovecraft as well you know and it was
the sort of you know pseudo scientific
racism
time like phrenology and well more like
the you know notion of the anglo-saxon
as the bearer of civilization but yeah
in Lovecraft stories the Anglo Saxon is
not going to win you know the the
degenerate races ultimately proved more
successful
well now that's interesting is it
because they're degenerate or because
we're falsely believing that we are not
more degenerate well I think that he he
thought he was you know Canada not kind
of he really was a racist who thought
that you know the the anglo-saxon race
was was better than everybody else but
it just you know marginally better and
it could easily fall into corruption and
degeneration as well but he has
something bad to say about just about
every other ethnicity you can come
across you know sometimes terrible stuff
yeah oh yeah you know
you know think about like his depictions
of all those you know immigrants who've
moved into places like Providence or New
York you know the story about Red Hook
for example right he definitely was a
nativist okay so I think that probably
plays some role in I don't know about
like the sort of anything having to do
with the old ones but it plays it plays
a role there's this fear of like being
contaminated of mixing of and then
another thing is he's imagining things
like you know a book like the
Necronomicon yeah right doesn't exists
well he there's actually quite a few
books he references yeah there are some
of them were invented by other authors I
found out like he co-created a fake book
with Howard Pyle Oh interesting
yeah yeah yeah I mean the he had a
pretty extensive correspondence with
quite a few other authors like Robert
Howard that meant Robert Howard you met
him I met Howard I'll how our pile was
that guy who did King Arthur right he
did that drawings for King Arthur okay
but Robert Howard did Conan yeah and a
whole bunch of others too I mean we know
him largely for Conan but but apparently
no he he did boxing stories what that
sounds awesome that was a genre back
then along with Eldridge boxing no no
Howard wrote these stories about boxers
who'd like he'd like write long passages
about how they're punching each other
Rick you know people people read that
stuff in the pulse you know that's
interesting it apparently he was really
into it oh he was he was an amateur
boxer himself he learned how to box to
fight him fight off bullies and you know
he grew up in Texas and he loved crafts
actually had this big correspondence
with each other
who was younger Howard you know I think
there he died young he did he committed
suicide
oh yeah yeah shortly after his mother
well his mother wasn't quite dead what
yeah he his father was a doctor and
Howard was very close to his mother who
suffered from a lot of ailments and when
she was on her way out he actually asked
his dad if somebody shot himself in the
head with a revolver would that like you
know would that kill him or is there any
chance that it wouldn't kill him and his
dad wasn't thinking they said yeah
they'd kill him
pretty dead and he won't his mom was
dying so he went out in his car and shot
himself in that killed himself right
after that conversation shortly after it
I mean his dad must have really been
kicking himself after that but I mean if
somebody wanted to do themselves in at
that time it was just a matter of time
but Howard and and Lovecraft they would
go back and forth as they you know
they'd write it into each other's
stories Lovecraft was saw the what he'd
created as sort of a public domain
playground yeah that's fascinating that
he'd let people do that
yeah he was way more successful than a
more contemporary author who tried doing
that Michael Moorcock Moorcock tried
doing that with his Cornelius he tried
letting people in on that well yeah when
he created the Cornelius Chronicles
centering around Jerry Cornelius and and
his brother Frank and I forget wait a
minute what came first the crane Ian's
chronicles or Elric Alrik because he did
because in the first Jerry Cornelius
book Elric shows up at one of the
parties right yeah no I don't think it's
the first I think it's like the third
notes first is it really yeah yeah I
only read first one so that's how I know
who's that no it's the condition of
Moosic no it's
it's the one where he combines with the
woman that's right okay that is the
first one yeah yeah starts with like him
and his mercenaries trying to attack his
brother yeah and a woman is one of them
and yeah and something goes wrong he
kills the brother kills the sister the
final program the final programs
interesting and strange book it's
unusual because all my other elder I'll
break all the other Moorcock books I
read except for master of the air
they're all sword to sorcery yeah
in multiverse actually speaking of
Michael Moorcock he's one of the
founders of the new weird actions
rounders okay so I think it's
interesting that Lovecraft even is one
of his letters mentioned the weird yes
you know writers of the weird and he
mentioned Poe yeah and Lovecraft was one
of the original writers of the weird
well there was that weird tales oh
that's right of course yeah of course
yeah it was it was an entire genre we
don't you I mean we talked more now
about like horror right then we do about
weird tales but it was sort of a
encompassing thing it you know I'd say
on one end you could like say it blended
over into detective stories on the other
into what we would now adays called
traditional horror and then you know
into science fiction yeah yeah it's a
broader fantasy - yeah and in nowadays
there's a little bit of magical realism
in there as well yeah I mean nowadays
people talk more about speculative
fiction as the super category and you've
got ya fantasy sci-fi horror science
fantasy magical realism you do and in
the new alternate history yeah new weird
there's even like a you know genres like
you know just Chinese futurism or you
know things like really yeah I mean
thing things that we don't get that much
exposure to it
it's a partner as a translation yeah I
think just so many great works that I'll
never be able to read because they won't
be translated well and but you wouldn't
have the time you know we live in we
live in an era where not only is there
so much content already produced but
there's so much content continually
being produced oh my goodness unless we
were immortal there's no way it's
impossible yeah even if we were immortal
but must we had you know everybody
stopped for a while there's no way we
catch up yeah I suppose exactly so we're
immortal it would just compound that
much faster
yeah and interesting I there I'm reading
a book called the Nazis breakaway
governments and the secret space program
something like that it's ostensibly
factual okay but it's all speculation oh
these are the people involved in Nassau
these they were all Nazis and they did
this and they were seen with these
people therefore there's there's a
breakaway space program and you know
look in the back of the book and the
publisher has a list and pictures of
well actually I went to their website of
all the books that they're publishing
and there's hundreds of them hundreds of
books of this type well they're easy to
write because the basic logic of it is
you know this could be this way and this
could be this way and this could be this
way so therefore this is the case right
right right
it's this foundation book it's another
genre and then you've also got the built
in thing of well if people doubt it
well they got to you okay yeah yeah you
brainwashed yeah excellent don't be a
sheeple you know that's right that's
right but that was part of Lovecraft's
message too wasn't it in some ways don't
don't be don't be food for yeah i mean i
think he were being harvested in his
view most people are totally out of the
know but you know the question that
that's raised it's a philosophical
question it's one that actually
descartes raises at a number of points
in some of his works not just the
meditations but also his last work the
passions of the soul if if reality suck
if reality is something really
terrifying or you know disgusting or or
painful are you better off knowing the
truth about it or are you actually
better off like living in comfortable
illusions and so you know Lovecraft
would say most people are living in in
fairly comfortable illusions they might
you know they might not have a
comfortable life that might be starving
they might be you know working their
their fingers to the bone for the the
proverbial man right but at least they
don't know that the universe hates them
and you know these yeah ready to rise up
nothing that we he writes do manners
yeah so ends it's a real question if if
you have access to that knowledge should
you pursue it well everybody who does
goes insane or dies that's true the we
leave a little you know Chronicle behind
they do yeah yeah it it usually ends
with you they come yes or the you know
the street lights are going out yeah
yeah not happy endings no yeah so there
any the universe is against you and so
is your fellow fellow man because
there's a cult a conspiracy to bring the
destruction about and you can't stop it
you know August Derleth nuked R'lyeh
R'lyeh is of course the ancient city
where Cthulhu is asleep and it rises
from the ocean every one monolith wanted
to have a cosmic balance so he
introduces these more benign elder gods
who are gonna somehow counterbalance the
old ones and you know elder things can't
believe he did it that's like that's
like well so impure that's polluting the
concept yeah so sojourneth is kind of an
equivocal character right on the one
hand he keeps Lovecraft alive after his
after Lovecraft's death by resuscitating
his
works he's the reanimate er yeah
bundling them together and and and you
know offering them any and he writes
quite a few things in his you know what
he terms of Cthulhu Mythos but the
things that he writes are deforming it
by trying to say it and not sanitize it
but to try to to make it more palatable
to give it some hope yes it's because
it's giving is it really that offensive
to have a story that's that dark I don't
think that's offensive I think it's
actually realistic I think Lovecraft is
true stories well metaphorically yeah I
mean I don't I don't think you know we
joke about Cthulhu for president but
that was a joke yeah oh I wrote that in
oh you did and he won deep down inside
know life is pretty dark right and in
the end it you can't win you can't win
life no matter what you do so it's
better just to forget about it unless
you're the Dalai Lama then he says
meditate on your death well he'll get
you know they get they get reincarnation
so shots right although the goal is to
quit doing that yeah what that does make
any sense to me well if you think about
imagine what it would be like to go
through life after life after life after
life and you know for it to be just the
same old however good it is it's always
it always winds up being the same Oh
[ __ ] oh yeah okay I can see where
our in couple thousand times yeah you'd
want to get off the wheel okay I think
that you know that makes good sense the
question is well what do you get off the
wheel - yeah I mean is it just
nothingness I mean that's different
different conceptions of what what you
know Nirvana would would be from
different schools of Buddhism or what
moksha would be in you know Hinduism
what do you think Lovecraft would say it
is oh I think he probably just just
dismissed all that's okay that's not
even yeah he'd just say shut up I mean
he has characters who there is a sort of
reincarnate
going on in some of the stories but it's
always because something some life force
has has survived and it's almost always
malevolent and it takes over you know
somebody's daughter or son or you know
great-grandson and pushes the original
personality and mountain and then uses
them just as a vessel
so reincarnation is almost like a
possession yeah or or a malign takeover
because sometimes they're stuck there
inside - right
what so they take over the the original
the proto and the person is like trapped
inside yeah we just helpless inside just
observing which would you know that
would suck yeah yeah that would be bad
yeah I remember I don't I think it might
be the shadow over Innsmouth there's
there's this mention that Lovecraft has
of these New Englanders who you know
believe in the Christian God and they've
got this sort of dour view and he treats
them as if they're just you know these
benign did savages who have no idea
what's really going on but at least they
stay out of trouble you know because at
least they're not making things worse
exactly yeah they're kind of joyless and
gray but they're not you know praying to
alien deities or you know something that
wants to turn the earth into some ball
of who knows what you know stent sending
out pseudopods to the right what was the
ultimate endgame there for old Cthulhu
who knows that's part of the terror yeah
I mean that the the funny thing is that
there's there's other beings fighting
against Cthulhu and his his brood yeah
you know but they're not on our side I
hate that were you rooting for Omalu
when it was float flying through our
galaxy I had no idea what to make of it
it reminded me more of Clark's
rendezvous with Rama than anything else
oh yeah yeah but you know I heard you
know we don't have any idea what it was
no we don't have nothing that's the
other thing
yeah you know why cause cuz we don't
that's not a priority for us well if it
was a priority we would have figured it
out we only had a handful of days right
we might have you know we might have
known more if we were actually you know
thinking I was talking with my students
about this in class you might might get
a kick out of this so I was saying
imagine like an alien race came here to
our world and they're like oh wow
they've you know look at what they're
doing they've discovered nuclear power
and they they have the internet now
they're all connected together and they
you know they've got all these great
computers and they're making all these
advances and then you know they look at
the content of what we're doing yeah
yeah so they mostly use this massive
tool for copulation
yeah depictions of that a porn or for
gaming yeah that's where like most of
our brain power is going into rather
than like figuring out I mean we talk
about well we're gonna go to Mars I mean
we're so uninterested in that as as a
nation and as a species compared to how
can we pack more players into this
massive you know right oh and and you
know will this will the sex robots take
over and beat us up yeah why is that an
issue because that's where we're putting
all of our money and I'm not complaining
because you know gaming and porn has
managed to drive a lot of technological
innovation has it these cameras that
were recording with right oh those exist
primarily because of the porn industry
serious oh yeah I drove technological
innovation but now I'm not saying these
particular can be history
oh let's say that's looking for she
wants led to the you know digital camera
revolution really but you know it is a
mistake
sense of priorities I think to bring
this back yeah we don't have that as a
species well we got a minute and a half
left dr. Sam yeah what's a great again I
go back in a second
today we discussed all philosophy until
the 20th century is relevant Deleuze was
wrong about Conte getting through a page
of philosophy we talked about holy
philosophy and I want to read it all
do you the Canon is a great place to
start it's there for a reason we can
disagree to disagree the philosophy of
evil HP Lovecraft
science is a religion Poe Robert Howard
Michael Moorcock August Derleth
the re-animator at least Christians
aren't making it worse and we ended with
Al Mamun what's your next project Greg
or what were you about to say you're
about to say something I don't know oh
okay
where can we reach you well the reason I
Oh website I'm on Facebook and Twitter
as well and of course my youtube channel
just type in Gregory B Sadler and you
can access about I think 1400 videos now
holy mackerel yeah that you are a
hard-working lot you're the hardest
working man in Milwaukee philosophy
that's a pretty small category oh you're
the hardest working man in Wisconsin
follow I know I'm good with Milwaukee
phone oh okay okay he just you'd be king
of the small hill exactly all right and
we are signing off
[Music]
you